look at this what do you think is going  through his head now I think he's  analyze oh sorry  this is what Magnus looks like when he's  analyzing  uh yeah and uh he is pinpointing his  mistakes he looks like he's just  realized where he could have won the  game  maybe he's looking at the opening as  well realizing that that didn't go well  it's uh we saw someone in the background  as well was that magnus's father I think  it was handrake yeah yeah maybe just  asking him if he wants any Refreshments  in the break  that's a disappointment for the world  champions ah wow Duda takes the lead you  guys this is going to be a dramatic  finish to this semi-final and what a  dramatic game